all I have for you is a word
tenant it'll open the right doors some
of the wrong ones too
use it carefully to do what I do I need
some idea of the threat we face as I
understand it we're trying to prevent
World War 3
I'm not saying are we getting you
[Music]
something was like I do you have an
interest in a certain Russian national
my experiment
here they won enough you can communicate
with the future
time travel no inversion a mitten poetry
you know shooting the bullet you're
catching it
what I've seen too much my work try and
keep up
and duty transcends national interests
this is about survival
seems bold bold I'm fine with that
thought you were going to say nuts
this is where our most coli
how would you like to die oh you chose
the wrong profession
[Music]
well that from here
hasn't happened yet
there are people in the future when he
does
I need tenant
we need to save them here and now
this reversing the flow of time wasn't
us being here now it never happened
you want to crash a plane but not from
the air no such master well how big a
plane
that part is a little dramatic
[Music]